Bullseye everybody. It seems like we're genuinely gonna get the character on the TV show. Finally. We've been asking for him for three seasons
It sounds like he's gonna have a pretty interesting art to like they're kind of combining a couple different versions of the character
If you guys don't know who bullseye is or why everybody's freaking out about him or you're not a big comic book person
But be sure to subscribe to get all the Marvel videos daredevil season 3 will be dropping later this year
But they probably won't confirm the actual premiere date till Comic Con this summer. Just a reminder to that
We're also getting Luke Cage season 2 at the end of June
So that will drop before Comic Con so we might also get a little bit of a teaser at the end of that for daredevil
season 3 I think most people understood the teaser at the end of
Defenders that we're gonna be doing born again because they gave a shout out to Matt Murdock's mom in real life gets sister, Maggie
Sister, Maggie is his mother in the comics. They cast Joanne Whalley to play the character. She's a pretty notable actress
So that's sort of the bones of the overstory but bullseye was not a part of the born-again story
It was mostly just kingpin versus daredevil
But what the TV show seems like it's doing is the FBI is gonna be a big
Organization during the season like homeland security was a big deal during Punisher season 1 but there are a couple big things that are happening
during daredevil season 3 namely the trial of the kingpin
But as part of that
Kingpin also said that he was coming for Matt
Murdock during daredevil season 2 not the daredevil kingpin also wants to take down the daredevil
But he doesn't know that Matt Murdock is daredevil yet
So you have kingpin coming for daredevil on all fronts in during the born-again storyline?
He finds out Matt Murdock secret identity. It just systematically starts to destroy his life. He tears him down
So the daredevil can be born again quote-unquote you get the idea
So that's kind of what Matt's arc is going to be during daredevil season 3. He's been torn down
He almost died now. It's his chance to be born again
But the whole thing with bullseye during daredevil season 3 is that we thought that they were going to cast him
There was a casting notice for a character that sounded like a version of bullseye from the comics
That was a little bit different from what most people know
But then it seems like we got what seems like pretty solid confirmation
Because somebody on the crew posted this picture of the official logo for season three
And it has bull's eyes
signature comic-book symbol right above the D as if he's going to be targeting daredevil during season three, but you know
How does that tied together what's going on with the born again? Storyline the kingpin Matt Murdock in the daredevil character himself
So the casting notice for the character that it seems like is going to be TV show bull's eye is
Actually listed with a code name of Steve
He's supposed to be an FBI agent
Described as being kind of awkward and needing the structure of the bureau to keep the darkness inside him
subdued so if you're not a big comic book reader you kind of need to know the history of
Daredevil versus bullseye to know how he sort of pushed. Bullseye over the edge by kicking his ass one too many times
So the bullseye character debuted during daredevil 131 just as this simple
Extortionist that was trying to pump up his reputation
So he wanted to take on the daredevil to prove to the underworld of the city that he was a total badass
Please hire me. So I make lots of money so daredevil kind of gets beaten
He becomes a relatively big mercenary in the city working for the mob the first time that anybody ever actually hires
Bullseye to go after daredevil is actually a mob boss in daredevil 141 that hires him not to go after daredevil
But to go after Matt Murdock because remember nobody knows his secret identity yet
So bullseye goes after Matt Murdock gets his ass handed to him by
daredevil couple issues later
Challenges daredevil to a rematch on live television to regain his reputation because all the mob bosses think he's trash now
Of course daredevil beats his ass again, and he slowly starts to go insane
So like you remember the Colin Farrell version of bullseye from the daredevil movie. He had this like insane quality to him
So what might be going on with the TV show is that you have TV bullseye working as an FBI agent
Trying to investigate the history of the kingpin what happened during defenders like this big shadow organization
It's slowly uncovering details about how daredevil was involved with that
So he's going after daredevil vigilante vigilantes exist in this gray area. They're kind of against the law
They do illegal things even though it's for good reasons trying to take down criminals
But you can kind of see how Matt Murdock gets caught in the crossfire as the FBI is investigating
Office so he probably gets his ass handed to him by daredevil while he's trying to take him in
slowly gets pushed over the edge over the course of the season until he eventually
turns into bullseye till he gets co-opted by the kingpin who then hires him to
Directly go after Matt Murdock in a future season. So I don't think that they're gonna kill off
Bullseye during daredevil season 3 I think we're actually gonna see him get a version of the kingpin origin story
we're like
He starts out of this normal FBI agent that just slowly goes
Insane and succumbs to the darkness within him because daredevil kicks his ass so many times at every corner
But I think the real question is is is how many people besides?
The kingpin will learn Matt Murdock secret identity because that's the whole idea is like once he finds out that Matt Murdock is the daredevil
That's really when he gets the upper hand
So obviously there's probably a lot from that born-again storyline that they're not going to do like Karen Paige is gonna be this drug-addicted
Person that sells out Matt Murdock's secret identity. That's actually what happened in the comics
So kingpin obviously has his hands in a lot of pies. A lot of drug dealers are on his food chain
So Karen page is eventually compelled to give over
Daredevil secret identity to this drug dealer to get more drugs the drug dealer passes the information up the food chain to kingpin
And that's how he learns Matt Murdock secret identity
So obviously they're probably not going to be doing that version of events on the TV show
It'll probably be people investigating the history of kingpin in the city in all these weird goings-on
the devil of Hell's Kitchen in what happened during defenders sort of connecting the Matt Murdock dots to
We're daredevil has been popping up
Like how come Matt Murdock is associated with all these things that Daredevils associated with and they're just putting two and two together
Oh my god, Matt Murdock is the devil of Hell's Kitchen
A lot of people are thinking that this FBI agent will become TV bullseye
Is it because so many versions of the bullseye character have worked for governmental?
Organizations before they succumb to the quote-unquote darkness within them. It just go full-blown mercenary. So let me know in the comments
what do you think about them giving bullseye sort of a
Season-long Ark the way they gave kingpin a development arc
Like he starts out as Wilson Fisk becomes the kingpin by the end of the season
So it sounds like the same thing is gonna be happening with bull's eye
But also really funny news too because Charlie Cox the actor has been filming daredevil season 3 for a while now
He hasn't seen infinity war
So he was actually at a Comic Con recently where people were asking him questions about that
Like what do you think about the snap sure what's going on with that? Where did the show fall in the timeline?
He says that he has no idea what the ending of infinity war was so he didn't know about everybody getting erased
so I think that's confirmation that daredevil season 3 and also Luke Cage season 2 pretty much every new season of the Netflix series are
Happening right before the snap right before the black order comes to the sanctum to get the time stone
What'll probably happen is is they'll wait till after Avengers for whichever seasons fall after that to
reference the events of infinity war
depending on how they resolve things like if they wipe everyone's minds so that nobody remembers that half of the universe got erased that seems
Like it's going to be a bit of a plot point
So there are a number of ways to
Explain how they reference or don't reference things on the Netflix series in the next couple of years
But there is a whole video that I'm working on. I'll try to post as quick as possible
Leave all your requests in the comments below but click here for all my other
Daredevil season 3 videos and click here for that brand new ant-man and the wasp trailer. Thank you so much for watching everybody
Stay awesome. I'll see you guys tonight